you got a star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame I know that's something thank you
no it's my thing do you know when they
tell you you're getting a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame do you have any
idea where it's going to be you get do
you get to decide where it's going to be
are there options I don't you know I
don't think so I don't think it's it's
my prerogative and I be happy with
anywhere as long as it's between Orange
and Highland on the north side of the
street right next to Harrison Ford I
want to be next to Harrison Ford yeah no
we're not honestly as long as it's a
part of the boulevard that doesn't smell
like you're and I'm cool right yeah you
have well good aim high now this is
interesting
lin-manuel Miranda also getting a star
and you guys were together when you both
found out that you were each getting
your star is that right it's pretty
crazy yeah Lin was on a shoot in LA and
he invited me down to have lunch with
him and while we're having lunch a guy
comes over with a cell phone and says
you guys should see this he plays a
video and it was the announcement video
of us getting selected for stars on the
Walk of Fame so it's pretty cool that's
neat
and you guys have been friendly for a
while because lin-manuel Miranda turns
out is a weird al' yankovic freak I mean
he really knows your work well well
we're mutual fans I mean I think he's
the most brilliant yes in the world
second that but yeah I mean he's he's
been a fan since he was a young kid he
he told me a story about how one time I
played The Beacon Theater in New York
like 1985 he was like a kid yeah he was
like 10 years old or something and you
know III do Yoda as an encore
you know pretty much every night but
yeah Lin said that he was in the balcony
screaming play Yoda play Yoda and then I
came out and I played yo Diaz like
why and then you wrote Hamilton your I
know that gave him the confidence if I
could do that I could do a rap musical
anything about the first yeah treasurer
that's amazing
you